this episode of life is short is brought
to you by weston weston hotels and
resorts have a single goal that's to
help guests travel well they've got
everything you'll need to stay healthy
and feel good while you're out seeing
the world so keep listening to find out
how their wellness offerings can help
you maintain your routine by eating well
moving well and sleeping well
here we go
[Music]
i don't drink wine anymore and it's
something that i'm kind of embarrassed
about sometimes because i know that's a
very adult thing to do and
the reason i don't is because you know
this story i do but i would love to hear
it again i was a freshman in college my
best friend james duffy's dad hank
came to visit hank was a very like
gregarious warm like loved having people
around and and so he took us all out for
this dinner and he was ordering so much
wine i think i think there were seven or
eight of us at one point we were on our
12th or 13th bottle of wine hank kept
ordering more bottles at one point i
remember going to the bathroom
and i was kind of wobbly
and i just
vomited
more than i ever had certainly up until
that point
i remember thinking it was like a
bathtub faucet had turned on and it was
just red it was just pouring out into
the sink
it was sorry they ruined bathtub faucets
for me
oh you were so into bath deposits
and then i like splashed some water on
my face and tried to collect myself and
stumbled back out to the table
and i was about to say i have to go home
or i'm you know i can't drink anymore
and he said nonsense a toast and he was
like in the middle of a toast and
i was hungover for two straight days i
felt so awful that i to this day can't
really drink wine you make him sound
like an old president or something like
william howard taft
yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your
wine free host justin long life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Applause]
[Music]
and with me as always is my
wine
enjoying your refined palate owning
brother yeah christian you do like wine
i do i do think there is an element of
[ __ ] in
the wine aficionado world like
cherries and yeah and like oak bark i'm
surprised you're not more into it
because you're very you always brag
about your refined palette
don't brag about it
you jokingly brag about it that's true
ah yeah wine wine so why are we talking
about this
your unrefined wine palette well i'll
tell you because our guest today is
an actress who is best known for a movie
called sideways which
is about
the wine tasting pretentious wine
drinkers yes it's about
people that i can't really relate to uh
but hope to one day uh our guest today
is virginia madsen and virginia oscar
yesterday yeah from the film sideways
which i just
recently rewatched it's so good
alexander payne made it uh but i
recently rewatched it and
their love of wine i think it almost
turned me off
of wanting to be that into why oh yeah
the way they talked about it and
it's a comedy so i think part of that is
on purpose to
kind of make them seem
a little extra but virginia madsen in it
is so charming
and likeable
uh
and
and real there's something so authentic
about that performance i've always
thought that about her as an actress
she's always so
even she's in a lot of horror movies too
and
uh which i love she's in a very popular
one called candyman
or candyman
um
she also is uh has a wonderful voice in
fact her voice is so
nice to listen to that she narrates a
podcast a podcast on wondery
double plug nice thanks called imagined
life yeah
it's kind of like an autobiographical
telling of
an individual's life and
throughout the episode they drop little
clues about who who the person is and by
the end it's revealed if you haven't
figured it's like a game it's kind of
like a game but it's also you learn
something about it's all written
obviously so i think they take some
liberties okay uh in terms of accuracy
so this show
will be a little different for one thing
it's a live show and we
recorded it at uh a westin hotel the
westin hotel in downtown austin texas
yeah we were right near 6th street if
you're overlooking sixth street yeah
which is like the belly of the beast yes
yes in fact
i when i first started going to austin i
remember like
mostly going to 6th street that was like
i was also in my early 20s and that's
where that's where the kids go
i my first time there was was for a
movie called idiocracy i went down to do
one day on this mike judge movie
idiocracy and and i just immediately
fell in love with the city so we were
supposed to record this on the rooftop
at the westin which is really beautiful
beautiful views of austin
uh like justin said overlooking sixth
street and it was hot it was like 90
degrees so it was really nice being
outside in the roof yeah but uh
we realized that it's a podcast and
people
uh listen to it and it was a pretty
windy day so we unfortunately had to
move it into uh like a nice big ballroom
well because again that area of austin
is like it's such a party area and it's
anyway austin's grade uh so
this is it this is our so yeah
uh this is our live
show
our interview with oscar nominee ooh
we'll talk about sideways we'll talk
about candyman for the horror fans out
there and we'll talk about uh virginia's
brother michael your uh michael manson
fans coming up next uh my interview with
the very talented virginia matson life
could be a dream sweetheart
so when we did this episode we stayed at
a westin i had stayed there before but
christian you hadn't right i actually i
stayed in one a few weeks earlier in
fort lauderdale that's right that was my
first experience with their eat well
menu
and you had talked so glowingly about
their eat well menu that i was very
excited to give it a shot well about one
item in particular because that's salmon
yeah well we've all heard about the
salmon on the well menu i won't talk
about it anymore even though i already
have too much i had a great omelette and
the portions are you know what sometimes
in hotels the portions are either way
too big or way too small and it's kind
of like stuff that you don't really want
yeah the food was really delicious and
you get half portions which is nice
and it they're all really good it's true
a really good omelette is hard to come
by i think especially on for rooms it's
really well cooked uh those cocktails
are really good too oh that's right
blood orange blood orange margaritas
those are delicious really good we had a
bunch uh on the rooftop and uh not a
bunch those cocktails are all made from
local ingredients i guess from crafted
at west end their eat well menu is
crafted with nutritious fresh and
responsibly sourced ingredients that's
the best way to source ingredients is
responsibly and every morning we're
there we got these delicious juices
because i've been traveling for a while
at that point and i i'm used to drinking
i'd make this green juice in the morning
i've been doing it for years and weston
offers they'd offer a lot of juices and
smoothies from west and fresh by the
juicery uh one of the nights justin was
feeling a little naughty so he ordered
uh the cookies
and
there were four cookies and they were
like each one of them was the size of
your face yeah as christian said massive
we really enjoyed the food you guys
should check it out sometime explore
more at westin.com a member of marriott
bonvoy
cheers virginia uh
i'm just gonna paint a picture for our
audience right now we're in the uh
westin hotel in austin texas
and also the heavenly bed
yes the heavenly bed did you hear about
it that's actually true where'd you hear
about the heavenly bed well because i've
stayed in many western oh really as you
can imagine i can when traveling around
and yes and the bed is actually heavenly
so i i forgot to paint the picture we're
in a westin you guys all came it's
nice everyone there are quite a few
people here uh they're at least four
thousand dollars
yes we have about i i would say we have
about 1500 right easily and quietly yeah
yeah um no there's it's a very nice room
and thank you guys it's true thank you
for being thank you for being here this
is new for us we're in the uh we're in
austin which is also
maybe my favorite city have you you like
austin yeah that wasn't for you guys
that was the truth uh
i love this city so much i lived here
for quite some time i had a i had a how
i had a house here i didn't i didn't
spend as much time as i would have liked
do you have a history with austin
virginia well the first time i was here
was probably
1988 or something like that you know
what's funny
sorry to interrupt there was just
somebody left their phone on it i think
that might have been mine oh okay well
even better there was it's funny because
you were trying to search for an answer
i just did an ice cube too if you can
hear that uh you're trying to search for
an answer the first time i was here was
and then it the ding went off of a text
ding
and you said it 1989 it was a really
perfectly timed yeah i think i was i was
doing a movie directed by dennis hopper
um the hot spot the hot spot
yeah
and even if you haven't seen it clap
and and i i was very young and i was in
this hotel where i could look out at
that bridge and see all the bats and the
bats are a big thing for the listeners
there's a huge migration of bats they
they stay under the bridge
millions like what is it does anybody
know the estimate is 1.5 1.5 later in
the summer the warmer it gets two you
heard two we got a two over here and
then i the next time i was back wasn't
until
last year for south by southwest oh wow
because i had a film called 1985
and and i was back here and everything
of course had changed remarkably
but the flavor of the city
and
the feeling of the city was still the
same
yeah and because i remembered it so well
and when was that hot spot that was late
early 90s no it was it was 19
88. i don't i don't really dennis hopper
directed that i didn't hear that what
was that yeah what was that like oh it
was so cool god
it you know he was because he was cool
and i mean that also temperature rise
because we were filming this
we were filming this like in july
and
and
and
it was so
extraordinarily hot
and
dennis
always wore
a beautiful suit huh
every day to work that cowboy hat he
wore a hat no no sorry he just was well
gr but ver a very well-groomed man yeah
handsome man and very handsome and he
would be and for some reason he
he didn't sweat
weird and i was just dying well it is
called the hot spot so that's it
probably a good thing but that's why he
wanted it to be in july oh wow
austinites know how incredible i mean
like there's no way i like the heat i
don't like the cold i'm i'm from chicago
and i
and i have a little post-traumatic thing
about cold so i like
the the heat but this was a bit much it
was a bit much when you have to kind of
look perfect and i was playing a femme
fatale
so i have to have
all this makeup and hair and eyelashes
and
tight things and
and
you know you have to kind of maintain
that for
you know 12 15 16 hours do you remember
why you wanted to be an actress and do
you remember that moment anything that
sparked it it was never a moment it was
just always i just
wanted to make movies i just loved the
camera i loved storytelling yeah also i
liked the male stars more uh-huh because
they got to do really cool [ __ ] yeah
yeah like i really liked lon chaney
character actors
character actors
there was a a show that came on at 11 30
p.m
that was called creature features
and my mother would let me stay up and
watch it on friday nights
i would watch all the old monster movies
and i was fascinated by the makeup
and very really fascinated by the
lighting in the original frankenstein
movie oh interesting
the lighting interesting if you see the
original frankenstein you it's it's
really i i can't figure out how they did
that yeah it's beautiful and the
werewolf and the mummy
and lon you know those those actors
really i wanted to be them well you
ended up doing movie versions of those
movies i mean yeah it's true i mean you
did
i would say candyman is as classic to
people now as perhaps those movies were
candy man is it i can i think it can
live up to that i think it doesn't and i
know you go to the horror you go to
conventions and you meet the fans
so you must see firsthand
what kind of staying power that movie
had candyman was a movie that came out
in 1992 and it is still something that
like people talk about people know i met
some people before this and i said oh
virginia madison's gonna be on and they
said oh my god we love candy man it's a
movie does it surprise you that horror
movies have that kind of staying power
or that movie in particular has had such
resonance with people well that one
doesn't surprise me that it's had
staying power because
i love making horror movies i really do
i love the genre but it's very hard to
find
a really good story and a really good
script yeah listen the slasher movies
have their fan base
you know that's cool
but that's not for me
but to have a story like this which is
like about a legend and about
a story you would tell around a campfire
and i just loved this story and i loved
that he was kind of like dracula that he
hypnotized me
and it was it was a romance yeah it was
a really romantic story and quite
groundbreaking for its romance at the
time because it was in 1992 and and it
was an interracial romance tony todd was
an african-american actor still is an
african-american actor um
as far as i'm strangely
as far as i know uh but we thought i
think we thought there was going to be
a larger conversation
when the movie came out okay we
all of us we meaning like the cast the
director
um and the director is bernard rhode
bernard bernard and clive barker wrote
based on a short story based on his
shorts i'm not telling you you know this
and we thought
that there was going to be a lot of
discussion about
the racial aspects of the story the
inter-racial love story yes me being
this white woman who goes into cabrini
green in chicago and all of us thought
this was going to be like a discussion
and we were all prepared huh to have
that we wanted this discussion but
everyone just liked the movie so much
that they like nobody else is that's
interesting really until now
it's become in the last few years more
of a discussion and i'm and i'm and i'm
happy about that yeah because at the
fourth before the time it was uh this is
1992. i just um yeah but nobody thought
of it like nobody brought up the fact
that it was an interracial love story
well it's not interestingly romantic i
mean maybe that's why oh god i think it
is
it's so romantic like we waltz and we
rise into the air and it's not that
romantic
yeah that's true but i think because he
was the
he
tony todd in that mechanic who plays
candyman
uh yeah but he's not freddy i mean like
he's really in love with me yeah that
scene where you are covered in bees
there's a seed in candyman if you know
the movie where both tony there's one
that's not in there that i did too
really
what's the scene that got cut and also
how did you do that with all those bees
well they just sort of pour them all
over you're kidding
and
like by hand because it wasn't cgi
because cj i wasn't as good then now it
would all you know i had to do this all
and i'm allergic to these things what
yeah so they would have paramedics there
and i was like
and everyone would be behind like a
like a net and i'd be like thanks guys
that makes me feel okay wait a minute
wait a minute i'm i'm not exaggerating
for people who haven't seen candyman um
no i mean i'm serious like i had to get
tested at usc and
and
to their he's
covering your face going up your near
your nostrils your orifices i noticed
you weren't don't go in your nose bees
are known to not go in noses no no well
that's comforting a little bit i guess
relatively
did they did was there a bee wrangler
who was like listen yes okay and they
gave you they
were you scared how did you feel doing
that well you know you learn a lot from
the bee wrangler before
and also you if you're allergic to bees
you already know a lot about them to
stay away from them yeah but to not have
to pour it on your face
these were baby bees so they're
they're they haven't developed anger
you're not flinching at all in this
scene it's a scene where you have to be
very because i don't want them to sting
me oh okay
wow and listen i never got stung but
tony todd got stung like
16 17 times are you serious because they
would get stuck in his
coat and everything and he's got them in
his mouth because he's in his mouth
oh my god yeah
once this
the take would be very short but then
there was the bee man who had this very
gentle
vacuum
because he didn't want to kill any of
the bees and so it took a really long
time for him to vacuum
all the bees
off you and it took so long and you're
like oh my god
vacuuming like a dust buster
yeah like a a little tiny kind of dust
buster thing and then the warmer you get
the more they love on you
and then you start to feel like they're
biting me
and he's like just stay still there's no
way and it would take a really long time
oh i bet wow but the the the scene that
i told you about and yeah i'm sorry i
will and
alluded to that got cut the original
ending of candyman
goes into a wall
and i am covered with 3 000 bees
you originally found helen
in a hive
oh my god with honey and they put all
that in there man
and then they just dumped them all in
oh my god and they cut that but they
have you know they put these
like the queen bee endorphins all over
you oh so you're fine what do you mean
oh so they won't sting you because
they're like you're our queen yeah they
think you're they celebrate you they're
they're all and i'm like my my character
is the queen so yeah like you do that
[ __ ] when you're a young actor yeah yeah
and yes and i had a completely
giant thing of three thousand bees all
over the world
and they take that barrel cut that
wow that's [ __ ] cool
and did they re so was that ending and
because the ending now is in the future
no they changed they reshot was that a
reshoot
yeah they wanted it to be more of a bang
it's weird because it's not as the thing
you remember about candyman is the bees
like that's the thing that kind of
separates and he was the character tony
tut's character dies from being consumed
by bees they spread honey out spoiler
alert um but uh that what a shame and i
wonder if you can find that on for the
candyman for the candy nerds out there
if you could find that on on some hidden
thing um
maybe jordan peele will find it oh yeah
okay so well we i don't know if we can
talk about this we can't we can cut it
but
if he will though they're really i told
him about it yeah i don't know if it
even exists anywhere so well jordan
peele is is doing can we i don't know if
we can say this we're going to say it
whatever we're they're they're remaking
it and we can cut yeah he's producing
and he he and his writing partner
they're doing another one and it's not a
remake it's not a remake yeah and can we
say
anything else about it i'm involved
cool
okay but it's not a remake all right
it's not a remake well that's that will
excite uh and so is tony todd that's
awesome but you also so you've done the
spectrum some of your early movies you
did i didn't know you were in zombie
high
which is a movie that as i was watching
it i watched the beginning oh you're
groaning she's groaning she put her head
there's that emoji i'm seeing things and
emojis recently that was that was in
1987 uh we should so you were very it
must have been one of your first jobs
actually no wait i'm sorry your first
job was class right no i was but with
zombie high i was like
really broke
okay and you don't have to justify it i
think no i am justifying it i am
justifying it and i i had a friend of
mine who wanted to produce this and he
said we can't pay you
but
this is a student film for usc
no and i was like wow cool and this was
after i'd made
yeah oh i mean i'd made
seven or eight movies oh my god and i
was really struggling wait virginia what
how how does that happen
i mean how how do you make not that you
make tons because
you don't always make a lot of money on
movies you make yeah everyone thinks
you're you know you know making that's
true jennifer lawrence paycheck but no
you're usually making scale
and
and because most of the work that i did
was
um independent films uh okay and so
after a while man yeah you're getting
low were you doing other jobs during
these movies were you
subsidizing it with uh
no maybe i should have
i know well hey
hindsight is 20 20. so that was that was
like an interesting opportunity to
work with students at usc
and then they brought it out
as a feature film which was oh my god
really well you can say it's on i mean i
don't want to encourage people to see it
if you're in but but this is not really
funny now it's really really funny and
it's really camp it's camp and fun and
and this to me is the mark of a really
great actress is when you can be good in
something bad and you're good enough
you're always good you're believable in
this thing and like well it's easy to be
good in a bad no it's not no
virginia that's nice to say but i
totally disagree i think when you don't
you're not supported by a script and the
jury you have all these things working
against you to overcome that i think
whatever you don't you're
not
i just won't compliment you again but um
but i think i think that's true and and
when you're watching i was watching i
was like there's a guy you know there's
always that stock character in those in
the 80s movies which i loved who was the
nerd it was just like that nerd and he's
got like glasses and i'm hanging and i
can't talk like this and he stumbles
over everything and i was like i know
this guy
yeah guess who he is guess who he is
i don't know why i'm making you guess
i'm looking at you but
who's gonna say it's gonna we built it
up too much it's paul feig
um who is
went on to become maybe the biggest
comedy director of all time but uh i'm
watching this guy i'm like i know who is
this so paul feig was i didn't even know
he was very interested so many
wonderful students that
were at that time they were so amazed
that i was a student yeah oh my god
they were so
they were so amazed that i
was this big hollywood actress you
agreed to do it and i was making their
student film oh yeah i would be now
they're
like writers producers and i thought it
would be cool to do the next work with
the new generation of
filmmakers
and there's i think eight or nine of
them that are like really big names now
haven't hired me yet i was going to ask
oh really
so paul went on to cast you in i'm so
proud of them
[Music]
sometimes i like to give myself an
excuse to not go to the gym when i'm
traveling by not packing my shoes and
like gym clothes especially when i like
to travel really light especially if you
don't want to pack a bag and you know
how much i hate checking a bag yeah you
sure do but you don't have to at weston
which is a nice thing all the western
locations offer on-demand workout gear
like running shoes activewear so
you don't have no
stuff you don't have an excuse plus you
get uh 24 7 access to western workout
fitness studios um they're all fully
stocked with trx equipment here's
another thing you could do and should do
you can set up a guided run
run concierge yeah if you like some
company and someone to motivate you a
little bit and or you could do it solo
if you don't want to run concierge and
they'll give you a run weston map and it
features a bunch of different three to
five mile
running routes around the hotel i saw a
lot of people such great trails to run
in austin so if you do stay at this
particular hotel that's something you'd
want to do it's a very cool option so
the run comments for people who aren't
lazy like us yeah what's their whole
goal is you yeah that's right their sole
purpose for being so check it out at
westin.com a member of marriott bonvoy
you have you have two siblings uh cheryl
and michael how did you fit in growing
up you grew up in chicago michael people
know michael madsen is your brother's
and also a very well-known uh actor
did he always want to be an actor do you
guys grow up kind of
doing stuff together as actors how did
that work well i think we were
you know our whole family was kind of
performers yeah my sister didn't want to
pursue it although she was
i watched her in musicals and
my sister studied
and
you looked up to her yeah but she really
you know we we had our dreams and my
sister
always wanted to
get married and raise kids
like honestly that's what she wanted to
do and she did
and she raised three
amazing
now adults oh wow yeah and you're close
still yes oh good and and michael you're
you're close with well i wanted to go
into it and
but
where we grew up and my father was a
fireman that um
you know guys didn't do that like he had
to be
a fireman
a fireman or a policeman really was
so was your dad like a real like
all-american kind of traditional man
type guy okay and i think he worried
about us with our hobby sure yeah oh my
god my i mean my parents were
supportive to an extent but my mom who
was an actress was by far the
less supportive of the two you know
because she knew the reality they worry
about oh yeah
like you can imagine if
i mean my mother was a writer so that
was different like she could see that we
should do this but my father being a
fireman was like
you know a chicago fireman more
practical yeah i mean you know what are
you doing yeah you know like kids don't
go up you know go make movies ah i think
he thought i would outgrow it and marry
a doctor or something
and what was the moment that he realized
oh she's now she's doing this this is
good she's making money was it that i
don't know if he ever got a bad
impression
he was very it was kinda yeah
like that yeah you gotta move it you're
doing doing with that david lynch well
he would still
he would send my brother
uh applications for
a forest ranger
or um
uh
paramedics in los angeles
and he would say he was doing movies
while yeah oh my gosh and he was like
yeah like
this is where you can go study to be a
nurse
he said you were so good with that
straight razor i thought maybe you want
to get a barber school well i mean
honestly i i think he just thought this
was
such a struggle and
a man like him didn't understand that
you could be unemployed yeah interesting
my father died a couple of years ago
and
and he
you know he oh
it was so hard for him
he was so ill
and so i was there with him one day
and
and he it was kind of giving me this
really
long
emotional look and my father was not
outwardly an emotional man and i was
like oh dad i was holding his hands i
was like dad what is it
you know can you talk to me
and she
and he said
how the hell can you live like that
oh my god like as an actress yes still
and i was like dad i have a pension
it's okay it got nominated for an oscar
dead
and he kind of like he just rejected it
you know oh wow but but but i will say
oh my god well cause still worried about
me yeah but i will say that my father
was
deeply
proud of me
yeah and
his children and said it a lot oh that's
good he was very proud of him he just
didn't understand probably but in his
day that i didn't have a job right yeah
yeah and by the way
it's a legitimate fear because
the reality of being an actor is there's
nothing as set unless you're on the big
bang theory like there's no
you know you don't know where that is
so many times i work for scale
but
you know independent films
that are very creatively
exciting
satisfying you're working with very
young filmmakers
those are the best scripts totally yeah
those are the best roles with sideways
like that would you say
no i got paid better for that okay okay
that was the best of both worlds i
couldn't believe that i could get paid
for sideways yeah and and it was so good
it's so yeah but in the script he must
he's such a great right alexander payne
wrote and directed and he had already
done election i mean so he had
citizen ruth so
what was that like how did that come
about um getting that movie that was
even a really tough
audition to get
everyone wanted that audition you can
imagine the people that wanted to be in
his next film
and so
everyone was trying to get in the door
and
i had an agent who just talked to him
and
i don't know why yeah he
because you were perfect you're right i
mean that's why he was in a position
where yeah he could make he could cast
people based on who was well not at
first no not me he said that he saw
something in my
photograph
in my headshot
and he said this looks like someone
who's been through a lot
and i was like
how did you take that how do you know
that
i didn't hear this until a long time i
thought this was a very beautiful
photograph of me
you know and i went through a lot of
good things
so i got one of the i was one of the few
people who got in the door wow not very
many people did after
my audition
a lot of time went by
because
the powers that be at that time didn't
want me yeah so were you during that
time during the waiting period did you
think oh this is not going to happen
it's amazing that i got the audition but
yeah i thought this is one of these
things i'm not going to get yeah it's
still stunning to me that at that time
considering the body of work that you
had
it would have been a struggle at that
time i mean i hadn't
i'd barely worked for 10 years
it was a very
intense struggle during that time i was
a single mother
i had a house
and i had no income wow wow and it went
on for a lot longer than i thought in
the independent movies
you're just not making any money who
knows
and so i i was still doing those but
i wasn't making enough to
support the household so when alexander
payne looked at that photo of you
perhaps he was correct and seeing some
struggle or that you had through
something oh yeah so what was sideways
like then knowing that it was yours then
how what was the process like working
with him i
because you're so good at i'm going to
take another minute there's that movie
so good in that movie it was mine before
it was mine before i went into that room
to audition i was like
in a really good space in my life oh
right i had strangely become athletic
and i had
way
well how does that help wait wait wait
wait because
you know when you have a kid you go
through puberty it was like you have
been i don't know he was by this time he
was
seven or eight years old and i was
teaching at his school and i started
doing everything and i started really
physically
taking care of myself so interesting and
sort of everything was coming together
yeah well so when i got that audition
i was like well that character isn't
physically together but anyway i felt
that this part is mine until they tell
me it's not
and what was it about the part that you
so identified with that you so felt a
sense of propriety about i used to go up
to that area in santenez all the time
i mean i had friends there and i knew
what it was like because they call it
the valley you liked wine
no i didn't actually do a lot of wine oh
really up there you just knew the vibe
i climbed trees and i went hiking wow
and
and i just loved that place on earth
yeah it was a sanctuary for me so i knew
how maya would feel you felt connected
to that place yeah and i knew
that when i read this it sounded the way
i speak when you got it was its uh sense
of was it like a celebration or was it a
sense of yeah you got it right oh i
broke down and bawled like a baby oh
good oh that's well because finally i
had a quote real movie you know like
i had this director that i so respected
and i had
paul giamatti was like the actors actor
yeah but it took me
three months till i heard that i got it
wow and i just kept saying please just
put me in a room with paul
oh you're having bread with paul no
because they were like oh we don't know
if this isn't it and i said i know i'm
gonna have chemistry with that man
just put me in a room and you can see it
yeah yeah cause i know that man is
dreamy yeah just put me in a room with
well you felt that way yeah
here's the first week okay okay
everyone's morning paul morning first
week of shooting yeah morning paul
by the third week it's like hey paul
can i go can i get you some coffee
i'm telling you this is the reaction so
he loves coffee no uh
so he grows he gets he has this magnetic
charm that kind of like it's not
obvious eyes that
i'm telling you man i'm not i'm not down
to you you by the way you're it came
from somewhere you're incredible in the
movie i was right i was right
now that makes a little bit more sense
and this is no knock on paul and i know
paul you probably say oh yeah what is
she talking about people don't look at
me and think oh i hate that i would say
that well
but that doesn't make any sense but but
the fact that it happened so you knew
before that based on
something
i just want to get in a room with him
let me show you they wouldn't let me but
then
i finally got the cast maybe they
thought you'd have too much chemistry
they were trying to protect you guys um
so i would ruin it yeah yeah maybe i
would just ruin it maybe he was like
keep her away from me
uh this is gonna change the course of my
life um you you but but you also do i
mean you talk about uh knowing that type
of
person that someone who lived in that
region who had a who assimilated to that
culture up there um
and you have this incredible voice i
don't know how to say this without
sounding weird it's like
syrupy voice
does that make sense is that a um and it
lends itself so well to the podcast
world
it's as does mine i know um well when i
was little and i
sounded i always had a very low voice
but did you so
when
i could pretend to be my mother and call
in sick from school
did you really oh totally
all right let's do a photo oh it works
let's do a phone call you're this is
going to be tough because you're little
you and i'm the prince what's the
principal's name who do you have to call
oh hi um can i talk to principal justin
please one moment please this is
roseanne i'll put you on hold thank you
i wish that i had jessie again okay
80s 80s um
yes this is principal justin uh who's
who am i speaking to hi principal justin
this is elaine madsen and elaine
wonderful to hear from you
listen elaine i noticed you didn't go to
the last parent teacher conference um i
was missing you oh you didn't see me
there i was
anyway listen
virginia has just come down with a
terrible fever we're actually on our way
to the doctor right now so
um she's gonna be need to need to be
excused for today elaine
anything you need any sort of moral
supports
anything i can do as principal a man
with power
oh can i ask you something is there some
kind of a flu going around school
because it seems to me that a lot of
children are getting sick maybe they
need to wash their hands more i'm gonna
make a note of that elaine this is a
wonderful idea in fact um i would love
to read that and i have to talk to the
local paper about that anyway hello uh
yes
there's no need for that thank you
we've gotta go okay
[Laughter]
um that was very good uh that was
amazing
so that worked
yes wow
and what did what did your did you
terrible i did it a lot you're talking
to my class superlative was most likely
not to be seen in class that's what i
got and most of it was based on and my
parents are listening and i have to just
accept they have to accept kids get sick
a lot but also we had bill collectors
and i could also pretend to be her to
get them off oh really yeah wow so
so now elaine must have found out about
this did she is this uh did she ever
find out about this later
but you guys see me
and
i'm dying to see this documentary you
made with your mom called i know a woman
like that by the way it looks like this
movie
it looks like exactly what we like to
explore on the show what it means to be
over 60 old yeah it's just that i can't
say the word it is like
because it's a taboo word this is a
discussion that we have
that is not a discussion that is in the
media
about being on the reality of being what
it is to be old
what that means to women and men my
mother as the director would interview
people and say
what is old to you
and our women are 65 to 95. people like
earth the kitt and lauren hutton though
really rita moreno
yeah and most of them are not
celebrities most of them but we have
writers and artists and
we have so we can still yeah yeah
and so it's sort of like
looking at their lives and
finding out that the through line of
these women in the upper decades of
their lives
are curious yeah
curious also they're most of them having
sex well that too that i yes and and are
proud of the level of sex they're having
it seemed like well because
there's more intimacy when we're young
people everyone's all freaked out about
how they look and they turn all the
lights out and they're like i'm sad i'm
sad
you know and it's the visual is removed
yes it's about the intimacy you know one
of the most sexual i was surprised at
that part i was like mom oh you hadn't
heard her yeah oh you hadn't heard her
speak that way well i mean i knew that
my mom was getting laid a lot at least
three times
more than you yes at that time how did
you know at that time
well because she had boyfriends you know
now she's married okay and has you know
has only taken one lover
well
an indeed a lover yeah wow yeah good for
her elaine and
yeah but i mean elaine has always been
like that and so i realized that i was
not living that way
even though you saw her living that was
she like that because your parents got
divorced when you were young and after
the divorce did she well
listen at that time
you know in the 70s like nobody knew how
to be divorced like nobody knew how to
be divorced with children right so if
you had
a girlfriend boyfriend lover
they didn't meet the kids
i mean so you never saw you never
witnessed any of that thank you
no
because that was just not what you did i
appreciate you not laughing when i said
hanky panky i don't know why i use that
i kind of like that 41 year old start
using does anybody say that anymore not
40 year olds hanky panky
it's an adult
this is something i want to ask you yeah
because on the description
of your podcast and and you've mentioned
it before yeah you you said i'm 41 and i
and now that i'm older
well i don't really go out anymore i
don't really and listen i understand
like i'm not about to go to a rave you
know
but like i'm i'm curious why you think
that you're older what's a time issue i
would say uh more time has gone down and
also
i don't know
but
i mean life is short like listen
we've been talking about the fabulous
elaine madsen yeah she's 85. i know and
this is what i appreciated about the
even the teaser that i saw for the even
the the brief scenes that i saw i think
maybe elaine who says
that word old i don't feel like i don't
feel old i don't know what that is yeah
i love that because it's interesting
you're saying it's not because i've been
thinking about this quite a lot in the
last day where uh the hotel room i have
is overlooking overlooking sixth street
in in austin which people from austin
people have been to austin know that
sixth street is like bunch of bars bar
bar bar yeah it's like bourbon live
music totally a lot of fun it's fun
totally and i and i was thinking about
the times that i used to have in those
in those bars and like you didn't do
that for very many years no but
there comes a certain reality it's not a
psychological thing in the sense that
well no because i feel like with you it
is
perhaps maybe maybe like do you feel bad
that you're not going out to these bad
that i'm not living i just wonder if you
feel like because you specifically say
you feel older listen here's another
elaine madsen i've said this a lot of
times
in your 40s you're free
yeah and in your 50s you fly
and you're not even done with your 40s
you just barely began well you're
assuming in your 40s feeling older is
necessarily a bad thing to me but i
thought you thought it was a bad thing
for you there's an element of tragedy
only because
well
it's not bad but there's an element of
tragedy justin
only because i so love life and i so
love
doing things and experiencing the world
that i i know and they i know they talk
about this in the movie that every day
they spin it in a very positive way
which is what attracted me to
wanting to see the whole movie now
there's the sense that uh life is
becoming richer yeah you know the older
you get the why i do feel wiser i feel i
feel a lot of good things i do feel like
too yeah me too it's so it's so much
better
so what inspired you to make that movie
then why
my mother and what about her how
independent she was how she was living
her life you admired it you wanted to
capture it because my mother
was so inspiring to me and she would
sometimes come to visit me almost every
time i made a movie and my mother would
just arrive
you i want to point out that virginia
put up her hands in a flourish she had
this kind of like grandiose
norma desmond and and she was a
filmmaker and a writer
and and she would just you know five
minutes later she'd be
talking to the dp or the
grip and
she would just be
curious
yeah just just very very outgoing
and i was like what makes her so
confident right yeah and so years later
i was like mom i want to know what makes
you a woman like that
why were you never afraid of aging
really
i want to know how you do that i would
want to yeah i said well let's make a
documentary and you'll direct it she won
an emmy for directing a documentary i
said so
you direct it and she
i don't have time to do that because she
had too much to do yes she had too much
to do
so eventually she got around to it and
we decided to do this wow and you and
you got you had access to all these
people like eartha kitt and lauren
hutton well no we we started to try and
find people yeah
and
got a phone number for rita moreno
and she took my phone call
and said oh
yes and it's a good impression once i
had her
we had a lot of people that signed on
because of her that's great and where
can people find that movie it just left
netflix and now it's on hulu and itunes
okay hulu itunes i want i need to see it
i think because i'm
just well there's a lot of there's the
men in this movie too yeah okay good wow
good i'll only watch a movie if they're
men
life could be a dream sweetheart
justin and i recently took a road trip
and along the way we made various stops
we couldn't always find a western hotel
to stop at to sleep unfortunately so you
know that feeling that feeling when you
stay in a hotel and the bed you just
feel like you're lying on springs with a
sheet over it they're like overly
springy soft bed picture the opposite of
that bed now and that's what that sounds
that sounds like it'd be heavenly well
that's what it's called you're not just
using that word no i was oh you were
yeah it was
it's a divine usually you just use that
word for like mint juleps and caviar
but these beds are so comfortable that i
think they deserve that word it applies
it is a heavenly bed
you're right i had a heck of a night's
sleep on that weston bed if you want to
really get the most out of a day you're
going to want a good night's sleep
before sometimes i need a little bit
more than a comfortable bed a little
extra a little extra what do you do when
you need that this is really
embarrassing to say but i'm sure they
don't have anything like this there but
you can admit it wow go for it it's
lavender bomb okay and it just helps me
ease tension and it helps soothe me to
sleep but i doubt they have anything
like that there not only do they have
lavender bomb what they have sleep well
lavender balm it's a mixture of lavender
and chamomile it's right next to the bed
you didn't see it no oh you missed it
every room has it see fortunately i
those beds were so comfortable that i
didn't need to soothe more attention
it's there if you want it and i know
you're someone who likes to eat right
before you go to bed i shouldn't it's
not i know but you do and at weston you
can order off the sleep well menu which
is a whole set of curated in-room dining
options packed with sleep enhancing
ingredients or you can get four massive
chocolate chip cookies that's what i did
and have those before is that on the
sleep well no but it's an option so to
learn more go to westin.com a member of
marriott bonvoy
hello hello
we'll meet again what's the next thing
what are you what are you doing next
what are you working on now besides a
wine a glass of wine
polishing that off no it's kind of
getting kind of warm
oh perfect
a gentleman
i i a handsome gentleman just just
popped up whose face you're caressing
wait a minute something i just happened
well he's very handsome a handsome man
just popped up with on cue with a glass
of i'm presuming cooler i see that that
bottle is empty now i don't know it
seemed like it was full and as as he
poured it into uh virginia's glass you
crest his face and i'm guessing you know
this gentleman i hope you know him well
i hope to get to know him oh
no i'm just ready i'm just waiting
i'm just kidding okay that's my fella
okay that's so nice that it was a nice
moment to witness um no i'm hustling man
i'm hustling yeah in this sense
no i don't mean i'm obsolete right
well that's how we're going to cut it um
no i've got a netflix movie called
operation christmas drop but i filmed at
an air base on guam
no kidding so bizarre how cool well
because it's a true story where they um
they've been doing this since i think 78
around christmas time they by parachute
they drop all these supplies for all the
people that live on those little islands
oh oh cool and school supplies clothing
water
food supplies they dvds of sideways yes
yeah the essentials i made sure that
they would do that
and uh i'm a very strict congresswoman
ah yeah and i want to shut this whole
thing down oh what's costing
americans are paying for this and i
don't like it what a great performance
just that little snippet yeah i'm hooked
yes
and then of course so i guess i'm sort
of the scrooge yeah was that like
playing that you you went from playing i
loved it yeah i bet i bet that's fun oh
yeah i like being the formidable woman
yeah i like being unpleasant what is
your most commonly used emoji
i don't use those i have a bitmoji
because my mother got a bit more okay
well bit emoji and she's 85 and i was
like all right if you get one mom i'll
get a bit moji but no i don't you know i
like to write
i would rather tell someone yeah
i'm old-timey that way yes i'm you would
want to say like i feel like poop rather
than just putting a poop emoji i would
say like species you made me feel like
[ __ ] yeah okay yeah i would say that i
would say
damn it uh that made me feel you know i
i would articulate yeah i wouldn't use
the poop emoji i think
i i think it lessens the it cheapens the
[ __ ] it cheapens the cheapest [ __ ]
although i have to say
the person
yeah
my brother sends emojis yes
yes
michael madsen sends emojis
awesome like prayer hands heart smiley
face tears like he's proficient
like he'll send seven or eight in a row
so they're not all like uh
knives and yeah they're not okay no all
the emotional ones
and i'm like well and i and i'm like i
can't send that back
well you know what's interesting about
that is like the way like he's the
toughest guy in the world yeah well he
writes poetry too i know well you're
right yeah and i'd rather he send me a
poetic line
than a cry-face emoji maybe that to him
maybe in context that to him is poetry
at the time i think we should just not
use them okay all right and i'll use but
but and if he found out about this he'd
punch you in the face
do you think he would
no no of course you know i had an
encounter with him of course no i did
have an encounter with michael that i
it's too long to talk about now but uh
it got it potentially punt face punch uh
he doesn't punch fever no no no he
didn't thankfully um but it was headed
in that direction if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play soccer soccer i've never been
able to run like that oh well that's
okay but i i love soccer and i love
gymnastics and so when you said you
became athletic all of a sudden uh
at some point in your life what did you
love doing well i did a lot of hiking
and i did pilates okay and then yoga was
the thing that captured me and hot yoga
suffering and hot yeah don't you want to
pass out during that yes yeah but you
love it it's horrifying do you nick you
do it
no
[Laughter]
okay
i thought that helps that helps too
um you well you
i don't know how to say this without
sounding weird but you're in great shape
yeah i'll just say it it's a fact you
were a great child because of that okay
because you i don't i hurt myself in
yoga like i would in a gym
okay oh well good [ __ ] that's score one
for bikram yoga no i don't do vikram
anymore oh sorry okay i take that back
just score one for regular temperature
no i do i do hot yoga and i do uh
regular oh
because she's confused i thought high
yoga was good no that one's too hot
and also i don't like that
practice yeah that's 105 degrees it
reminds you the candyman days yeah it's
not no i do uh
big room and um i i i don't do big room
but i do yoga in a warm room okay and uh
sensible temperature yoga i don't know
what to call it um if you had to live
somewhere else outside of
uh l.a you live in l.a now yeah um if
you had to live somewhere else where
would it be italy
okay
yeah you've been many times oh god i've
never been i know i've learned i just
when i'm there i'm sort of like why am i
here yeah why am i
in los angeles yeah what's your favorite
movie of all time
sunset boulevard oh weird i just i
mentioned norman desmond earlier um
what a great movie i love that because
it was in black and white and didn't
need to be i also i'm a huge fan of
gloria swanson her voice yes yeah and
she had this
control over her voice even though she
started
in silent films
she's made william holden into the
gigolo yeah and he's having spoiler
alert he's having an affair with a young
writer at the studio yes
and so norma
calls
and she goes
hello
hello
is this miss betty schaefer
this is betty schaefer
who's this
do you know joe
what do you mean joe say
and she said that's amazing
do you know where he lives wow do you
know how he lives that's amazing what
control and then he comes in and grabs
the phone is like yes come over and see
i'm a gigolo wow
i don't take this the wrong way but i i
don't know how to say this i hope this
is inherently insulting but you should
play that part
they should do that no they should never
redo that movie whatever maybe a version
of that character what a great but i
just loved the way in those movies the
way
they
used their vocal skills yeah and the
lighting in that movie and also nobody
says
if you get up dinner with three people
dead or alive whom you've never met oh
betty davis
harriet tubman
and stephen hawking
wow it's a hell of a dinner and they all
have
they all have fortitude
yes
there are all three
incredible survivors
yeah
and i don't know enough about
harriet tubman
i want to know how she did that and
stephen hawking i would like to just
talk about like secrets of the universe
because i'm a huge you know i love
astronomy and i didn't know that but you
seem like a very curious person i know
your mom is and and you had that impetus
to make the movie about your mom i think
you were compelled by the same thing
that you would be you know that's why
that dinner would be so interesting uh
who's your favorite muppet okay this is
an issue because
are the sesame street yes
part of the muppets yes virginia
river grover grover grover was the best
what about grover why
because he was he just had so much fun
that's all he wanted to do is have fun
and like shake his arms and see those
girls
suddenly elmo comes in
like the i'm the new shiny bright thing
i'm elmo like we know you're elmo
um
listen i was so
into sesame street growing up as a kid
me too so i was like really trying to
get my kid into it
and he was like why are we watching
puppets no
he's just heartbreaking is that and i
was like don't you like elmo don't you i
was just too neat don't you like grover
but grover was suddenly just not on very
much i know i know a girl like it's like
if there was a new character on friends
and suddenly
rachel was just a guest star perish the
thought yeah anyway um
uh if you could have one superpower what
would it be i could fly
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life if you could stick to one age
50 50.
yeah yeah great
oh that's exciting that's comforting and
exciting me yeah i i really i mean i'm
over 50 now but yeah like 50. yeah
that's really nice
nice time for me if you could be
reincarnated as a non-human animal what
would it be i guess i would be a yeti no
no i think i'd be a dolphin oh shiny i
just think they have an excellent life
beetles are stones
stones yeah but listen i love the beauty
sure yeah but you have a heart did you
read keith richards book no oh you must
read it's it's more about music and
blues than it is about like trash
talking but the trash
is really great oh
i bet he could but yeah but i
i didn't understand the stones when i
was growing up i really didn't neither
i've appreciated them more than
man
i saw them in concert and i was like
all right yeah cool how do you feel
about the beyond do you think about the
next part of life and how do you feel
about what happens next
i don't know
i think about it differently
than i did when i was in my 20s and i
was
meditating and
having crystals and
getting
going to someone who was channeling
spirits and you weren't into that kind
of stuff oh yeah yeah
you have to get there to when it's the
end to when you really know what you're
talking about
when it becomes a reality that you're
facing is that yes and yes i think there
is
something
beyond here of course the older you get
the more you think about it yeah and i
don't know what i think about it yeah
that's okay yeah
do you think about legacy do you think
about how people might remember you
after you're gone off no now yeah
yeah i mean if if they do i mean
i think if i had
people who
loved me
that remembered me then
and if i left a good legacy for my son
yeah if he remembered his mom in a good
way that would be the that would be the
most important thing for me yeah that's
nice thank you for doing this thanks for
coming you guys
stick around for a long time thank you
yeah thanks everyone who stuck around
it's uh there are three people left um
this was a real thrill i i so appreciate
you being open and sitting down and
doing this thank you thank you
so
so
that just happened that happened
in real life in real time yeah it
happened a couple of days ago actually
yes
what were your first thoughts
well you mentioned this a little bit in
the beginning but
her voice you call her voice
syrupy is that and i was wondering
it sounds
too gross to be a compliment
but i think it's a perfect word for her
voice she has an amazing voice yeah she
does i didn't mean so
it's a little katherine hepburn right or
a little uh when she was doing uh elaine
the graduate oh yeah yeah and bancroft
totally oh is it a little ann
ellen barkin had a great
[Music]
speaking of good voices
um i wonder why that is a is this going
to be too much of a tangent why is that
voice considered sexual
sexual or sexy sex what's the difference
uh
sexual and sexy are different i think
sexy why is he consid you're right why
is it considered sexy we can get into
that if you want no no no uh it's
considered sexy uh if i had to guess i
would guess there's an element of danger
to them and mystery to that voice and
they smoked cigarettes
and they were katherine hepburn they're
kind of um
there it adds a level of mystery and
intrigue i think
same reason that i think a male a deep
male voice
is more alluring than a very
high-pitched male voice i think
high-pitched voices in general
you kind of lose something about uh
they're it's not as deep either yeah you
lose depth what
depth i think is sexy and and that's why
a lot of like uh depth is sexy
oh you know what's sexy death
johnny depth
um
i'm glad you finally admitted to uh not
really living in austin because we
have made fun of you for so many years
about whenever you meet someone you're
always so proud
because justin did have a property in
austin for a number of years but he was
so eager always to say i live in austin
part time he loved telling people that
but he didn't really he came like twice
a year for like a weekend at a time
but but in this interview you finally
admitted you're like i don't i don't
you're like i don't really live in
austin that's you're like i had a place
there but i didn't really i loved
identifying yourself as
i know because i you like it i like it
and i like the people and i like i kind
of aspire to be that type of person i
was hoping uh she she told a story about
working
with dennis hopper dennis hopper driving
a movie and
i i was so i thought that i thought
there was going to be
she was like yeah
i was like
here it comes and she was like yeah he
was really well dressed yeah he didn't
swim well groomed
like what i know that was so
disappointing
also because i just seen apocalypse now
at um at the arclight they did like the
final cut the final version of
apocalypse noun and uh coppola and
martin sheen and
a bunch of the cast from the movie were
there uh obviously dennis hopper was not
um but re-watching that movie and seeing
how
insanely good and and by insanely good
dennis howard was i mean
he was
obviously like real and he's such a good
actor but
he seemed like he was and on something
like ins like kind of like losing his
mind and of course that's the part he's
playing too but there are all these
stories about dennis hopper in
in that movie that he
that was so fun like he had taken all
these i mean he was on drugs yeah i know
that like
there's so many stories i know about
he's like he's notoriously a legend yeah
yeah and he's well-dressed he's that's
cool yeah i didn't know that i mean i
didn't know that i i remember seeing the
trailers for that movie when i was a kid
and thinking oh maybe obviously a movie
i couldn't see because it was like
r-rated for sexy time for sexy time
sexual time sexual times
uh
she talks about her upbringing and and
her father
being like a very traditional
old-school man like a man's man and that
made perfect sense to me that michael
madsen's father is that kind of his dad
is that you know traditional oh yeah
doesn't that make sense totally you talk
about this a little bit in the interview
but uh i think it bears repeating that
he is a poet so i mean most people know
him as an actor he's in classic
tarantino movies but yeah maybe even a
greater side of his personality i think
is uh his poetry there's robert frost
there's walt whitman
and there's michael madsen uh and i can
just read an excerpt from one of his
poems right now uh one of my favorite
ones is called
it's called hammerhead
man i think the hammerhead shark is the
most bizarre looking creature i've ever
seen
what is the deal with that head
that was from hammerhead by michael
madsen so everyone should go uh
find the full poem but he has uh
collected works you can get on amazon
and uh check them out highly recommend
yes so that came up and um a big
surprise there was that uh michael
madsen who we all know if you don't know
him he was in he played mr blonde and
reservoir dogs uh he it was the father
and free willy uh he plays a lot of kind
of like he's like robert mitchum he's
got if anyone's ever put those two
performance
two performances right next to each
other well they're two of the biggest
and you know i think that he's done i
think they're two of his biggest movies
and then of course i mean tarantino
really
resurrected him uh with kill bill but he
was supposed to play um
travolta's role in pulp fiction and and
uh instead he did
wyatt earp i guess and and so
tarantino and michael madsen didn't
speak for a little while and this is all
a well-known
hollywood lore save it for the michael
yeah but he uh the it was surprising to
learn that he used quite a few emojis
that was funny when he said knife
cigarettes
like no no prayer hands teddy bear heart
he's like knife sunshine yeah
yeah it's funny to picture i wouldn't
have thought that whereas virginia
shunned
emojis refused virginia seemed like she
was very ready to answer some of those
short questions and i think we were very
flattered because she
uh when we met her she was very sweet
very um very complimentary very
complimentary yeah about the she's she's
a listener of life is short
so i think she had uh some of those
answers she had thought about in the
chamber i think she was ready to go with
some of those answers which is nice
because it means she
has thought them through and she's you
know
she
but she does not like emojis this is sad
but have you noticed that the older the
more time that you've had with emojis in
your life
the more you're using them yes i've
noticed that about myself and i don't
like it this is even worse i'll take it
a step further i've noticed i mentioned
this in the interview i mentioned i
noticed that i
think
in emojis now i emojis come to mind when
people have physical reactions like when
virginia when i mentioned zombie high
and she groaned and put her yeah in her
hand i thought oh that's like that emoji
isn't that sad yeah
i'm sure that's very common though it's
like a return to hieroglyphics how is
this going to cave drawings yeah it is
we're regressing i mean there's
something nice about that i mean to play
devil's advocate
there is something nice about that being
a universal language because think about
all
languages that exist that separate
that's
the
people yeah um and it's really hard to
connect with people because you speak a
different language but everyone speaks
the language of slapping that's true
yeah in fact one of my favorite things
to do every every year i go i go down to
nicaragua and i
uh
work with this
home for kids and it's so
frustrating to not be able to
communicate with these kids so the only
thing i can really do is use body
language and and
my face and stuff and it's a fun
challenge uh but but it works i mean if
you can commit to it yeah so maybe
that's yeah at one point she calls you
out for being old or feeling old and she
she's like you know i have a bone to
pick again which told me that she does
in fact listen to the show because you
do reference be getting older and being
40 now and in real life you mention it
fairly often it's something that i'm 40
now that's true it is it's coming up a
lot in it something i
i guess i struggle with it i don't think
it's a it's a struggle like uh an
insurmountable struggle but see i think
she has a point it shouldn't really
matter that you have this number
if you want to go
out to a bar on sixth street true and
that number shouldn't prevent you from
doing so but i also think
you have a point in that
just physically alone i know
the thought of dealing with
because when you do go out and you do
more quote-unquote younger person things
it's just not as appealing so and you
tried to make this point which i agreed
with is that it's not necessarily a bad
thing to be aware of your age because
getting older is a really good thing in
that
you
learn lessons and you're wiser and yeah
maybe your joints aren't more but and
your and hangovers are worse but it's
kind of good to have that perspective i
think so too i think the trade-off is a
positive one but the fact that my body
just can't handle alcohol the way it
used to it's good i don't need to
the idea of going out the way i used to
is um not appealing to me anymore
because that if for no other reason the
next day is kind of wasted and like the
thought of wasting a whole day knowing
how
precious days are is is really
depressing to me the night of
just a few nights ago the night of this
interview justin and i oh right we
are in the hote in in the westin hotel
still and
the sixth street like we said it was
it was right around the corner so we
were like just out of curiosity
let's go out there and and and see if
it's you know check it out check it out
there were so many we could see like you
know when you're looking at that from
like 20 20 floors up and you see like
people are kind of little dots and
they're all these bars there's something
inviting about it still to me i have
that in me where i'm like i want to jump
in there and she had also virginia had
just recently said oh come on age like
she doesn't write
and she and she did make a really good
case for she did not getting hung up on
age so i think we were a little inspired
by that
and we went out there and
it was like a zombie movie first of all
everyone was
college aged i think and
like fist fights all around us yeah it
was scary we were i was legitimately
scouts like i gotta get back to the west
end yeah
yeah it was like being able to get back
to eat well menu yeah
yeah it was like being on a drunken
zombie safari
where we like i had my hannah we were
just kind of like we must have looked so
out of place and like we must have
looked like we were watching a zombie
movie yeah uh at one point her speaking
of age just being a number uh virginia
had uh her lover her boyfriend oh yeah
was at the show
um a young man named nick and at one
point in the interview
he
dutifully and and and
chivalrously i would say yes uh
scampered up onto the stage to refill
her wine glass yeah very nice move yeah
she had said something like well my wine
has has be has grown warm or something
that's my virginity mats
well my wine is a bit warm now just
without missing a beat uh got up and and
refreshed
her glass i was thrown by it like oh
that i just thought it was like an
audience member being nice and maybe
borderline inappropriate
like by refreshing this the guess why
and then she
caressed his face with the back of her
hand
like very sensually uh at one point
within the span of two minutes you spoil
the endings of candyman and jeepers
creepers and
you you have to get better at your
spoiler alerts because you very often
you'll you'll spoil something and then
after you spoil it you'll say kind of
under your breath the spoiler alert well
like that's
yeah it's like a fire alarm that after
like the houses and rebels it's like
yeah i but you know i will say i
disagree with you on that a little bit
because i don't think a spoiler alert is
necessary for a movie that's over it's
let's say 10 years old
why well i've never seen candyman
doesn't just because i haven't gotten
around to it yet that's true
well yeah because if like at this point
if you haven't there's you must not have
much of a desire to so then like
yeah i don't know has been out for 25
years i disagree back because i think
people go through phases where it's like
i'm getting into a certain genre of
movie and oh yeah i've always heard of
candy man i want to see it yeah but i've
never i can't i'm i'm bleeding that is
true you know to your point i've been
binge
it's a really embarrassing sentence but
i have and uh but if you were to for
example like to your point if you were
to spoil the ending of entourage even
though i pissed i'd be pissed yeah even
though i kind of know that
drama gets a joke
i guess that's not why i watch andre
it's not like breaking bad we're like
it's building to this thing exactly but
the end of jeepers creepers when you
lose spoiler alert pause
pause when you
lose your eyes is that how it ends yeah
spoiler alert i said yeah yeah
that is you're watching this whole movie
and he's building to something and
um you know the first time i saw that
movie was with mom to uh a theater in
bridgeport
which is still there and uh it was
packed and there were three
larger women in front of us and they
were furious with my character because
my character does the spoiler alert my
character does dumb things like we got
to go back and investigate that thing we
saw and that with that shady character
and at the end of the movie as they were
getting up
and my i'm dead in the movie and my eyes
are out and mom was crying and and the
three ladies in front of us as they're
getting up they go i'm glad he died and
they were like celebrating and mom i
remember she started like i could see
her start to get up to say something
like she was defending her son and i
just i held onto her arm and i was like
and i had my hat down like over my eye
as much over my face as we go and i said
mom just let it go
yeah
i wonder if virginia madison had a
similar i'm sure with elaine
finally i think my favorite part of the
whole interview is a lot to choose from
but i think my favorite part was
of all 42 minutes when she said my
favorite part was when she said
you know i love astronomy and you just
said i didn't know that
why did she think that you knew that she
liked astronomy i don't know i don't
know that made me laugh so hard you know
i like it well
had she already said that she was into
crystals and stuff when she was younger
yeah but that's not astronomy i know but
like new age kind of maybe [ __ ]
spiritually
my favorite moment of the show i don't
think we can use it because it won't
make sense to people but
maybe we can try to describe it there
was at one point i forget what had been
said but
somebody a very like engaged audience
member very like vocal audience member
went um
he was like he started wait wagging his
finger back and forth like shaking his
head shaking his head like uh no no i
mean what i heard when i saw this was no
no no no no no no he wasn't saying that
but he was just making that like head
shaking and finger wagging like no no
tis tis yeah it was a tissue it was yes
yeah and so i go i was like oh oh well
you don't agree sir obviously he doesn't
agree and he was like no and the people
at his table were like no he does
and i had confused
a no no no for
confused
queen he was saying yes queen yeah um
should we read a letter the ass queen do
you have it here can i hand it to you i
have it oh you do um
this is from jeff b the subject is
life's rules justin christian love the
podcast thank you jeff
truly isn't it nice to hear that there's
something really yes but stop
editorializing
sorry
tomorrow is my 50th birthday whoa i am
reminded everything you didn't say no no
i know that was mine sorry all right no
more editorializing i'm just going to
read it i'm reminded every day that life
is very short in the last two weeks i'm
a retired navy chief served 22 years in
the navy i've lost someone i know
that is my age
one to cancer and one navy brother by
his own hand life is definitely too
short that's why i enjoy your podcast
i've come up with some rules that i live
by
one be kind to everyone you meet you
don't know what they have going on two
watch springer or cops it will remind
you your life is not that bad that's
funny
three keep a bowl of chocolate on your
desk at office
four let the other guy go first at the
roundabout five pay it forward not only
at starbucks do it at burger king
mcdonald's any restaurant even the
grocery store six let your dogs lick
your bald head
well and if you don't have a bald head
shave your head and let your dog lick
your hair or any bald part of your body
if you don't have
not any okay okay
seven cook pancakes at your church's
monthly breakfast that's very nice eight
buy whatever kids are selling outside
lowe's
nine dance randomly in public
ten take selfies with family as much as
possible uh and then jeff included a
photo of his family very nice looking uh
family thank you jeff um happy birthday
and happy birthday yeah those are good
rules but thank you jeff and thanks for
everyone else writing in uh and if you
have uh any rules that you like to live
by or
questions or stories uh please write
into life is short at wondery.com and
thanks for guest virginia madsen
and to her lover nick and everyone who
participated in our our live western
show to the whole audience um it was a
really nice audience and thank you guys
audience the most important audience
you listening at home or wherever you
are thank you for doing that
and stay tuned for a little voice memo
[Music]
[Music]
and it's produced by my brother
christian long it's also produced by
megan monaco and our senior producer is
michelle mish lands audio engineered by
marcelino viapando executive produced by
marshall louis and hernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
this is a poem called hammerhead by
michael madsen
man i think the hammerhead shark is the
most bizarre looking creature i've ever
seen
what is the deal with that head
what was god up to with that one
get out a shark book and look one up
take a long look
it's crazy
it makes me crazy
kind of like it got itself caught in an
underwater vice
smashing its head into a hammer-like
silhouette
that was hammerhead by michael madsen
that was a fun voice memo right
anyway thanks again to weston for
partnering with us it was nice to be
your partner so guys be sure to check
out all their incredible healthy
offerings from the eat well menu their
luxurious sleep well essentials
including that bomb that we talk too
much about
and including that heavenly bed
and all of their move well on demand
workout gear and running options explore
more at westin.com it's a member of
marriott
bonvoy
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wundery app
[Music]
you